what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video today I want to
talk about Arya Stark and her potential
role during the war for the dawn but
before I get started I want to talk
about the big leak that happened
yesterday by now I'm sure everybody is
probably aware that there was a massive
hack on HBO a few days ago and over 1.5
terabytes of information was stolen
including at least one episode of Game
of Thrones which was episode 4 the
spoils of war the news of this episode
leaking online was all over YouTube and
Twitter yesterday and everybody was
blowing me up asking me if I had watched
the new episode or if they wanted me to
get the link from them to watch it and a
few of you even asked me if I was going
to immediately make a full review about
the whole episode to be honest with you
I would love to drop a full review about
that episode right now but I do not want
to do that just yet but there is one
scene that I do want to talk about with
you for right now this clip that I'm
about to talk about will be a spoiler
for episode 4 so please if you do not
want to hear it I would recommend
clicking off of this video for now when
I got on YouTube yesterday I noticed
people had already uploaded nearly every
single scene from that episode but I was
trying my hardest to wait and watch the
full episode on Sunday night right along
with the rest of the world but there was
one clip that was on YouTube that I did
watch early and the only reason why I
watched it was because Sky Atlantic
actually released that clip a few days
ago and I already knew what was
happening in it in the clip that I'm
talking about is despairing scene
between Arya Stark and Brienne of Tarth
in the preview trailer for episode 4 we
can see Arya Stark on her horse
overlooking Winterfell and at some point
during this episode Arya will make it
inside of Winterfell is courtyard and
she's going to get into some kind of
sparring match with Brienne I did end up
watching the entire fight scene in that
clip but I do not want to show the clip
here because I'm not trying to get in
any kind of trouble for showing any of
the footage too early but I'm sure most
of you have seen it by now and know
exactly what I'm referring to
during this training scene I did notice
something very interesting and I noticed
that Aria had the Valyrian steel dagger
on her hip already now of course most of
us knew she might end up with this
dagger at some point because
Entertainment Weekly released faux
of a stark reunion and Aria had this
dagger on her hip and all of those
photos I was kind of surprised they
revealed that in an official photo but
I'm happy they did and after watching
this sparring clip it's now confirmed
that Aria will have some Valyrian steel
and it's obvious this dagger is very
important to the story this Valyrian
steel dagger is the same one that was
used during an assassination attempt on
brand Starks life back in season 1 bran
Stark ended up witnessing Jaime and
Cersei having sex in the tower while
they were at Winterfell
Jaime pushed him out the window but as
we all know bran did not die but it
didn't stop someone who was very
motivated to make sure bran was silenced
thanks to lady Catelyn and summer brand
it survived the second attempt on his
life
and Catelyn took the dagger to King's
Landing to tell Ned what the hell was
going on and everyone assumed that had
to be a Lannister that wanted brain dead
because they were really the only ones
who had something to worry about that
bran might have seen the last time we
saw this dagger was on Ned Stark's desk
when he had this in his last meeting in
there with Littlefinger and the dagger
hadn't been seen ever since
so in Arya all of a sudden pops up
wearing this dagger I automatically
assumed she must have killed
Littlefinger to get this but since she's
wearing it in episode 4 she must not
have killed him just yet to get it
because I don't think Littlefinger would
be dead already
but in a strange twist of irony I do
think she will end up killing
Littlefinger with this dagger I think
it's safe to say most people probably
assume she's going to kill Littlefinger
with this dagger but she may end up
doing much more with it when I was
watching this boring scene with Arya and
Brienne I couldn't help but get excited
after seeing just how badass Arya has
become everyone knows Arya is a
certified killer but we have yet to see
her go up against someone toe-to-toe
that's as good as Brienne Brennan's
resume speaks for itself I mean she's
kicked a lot of ass but Arya has
officially leveled up she already has
stark blood in her so that makes her
special already and important to the
plot unless your name is Rick on of
course but with the war for the dawn on
the horizon Orion may end up being very
useful although Jon might not want her
on the battlefield but I think Jon
already set the stage for Arya to be out
there with him in the very first episode
jon said he was going to need every man
woman and child training
prepare for when the army of the Dead
comes and let's be honest here if you're
going to have any woman fighting with
you who would you want to have by your
side it would have to be Brienne aria
and possibly even the sand snakes if
they were still alive because at least
in the television show
they have been some of the best female
fighters we have seen so far and now
that Aria has Valyrian steel this makes
her even more important for the war to
come because everyone knows that
Valyrian steel was one of the few things
that can actually kill a white Walker
now some of you might think aria is way
too young to fight against the army of
the dead but in the television show I
don't think she's a little girl I don't
think they can pretend that this girl
playing Aria is 13 years old right now I
think she's at least 18 or older in the
show I mean it is season seven now so
many years have one passed since we
first saw aria in Winterfell but there
was something else I saw while watching
Oriya in Brienne trained Aria was
dodging her sword just like the white
Walker was dodging them at hardhome and
I really wish I could show you the clip
of Aria fighting brand but just look at
this clip from Hart home and watch how
this white Walker moves as the thin
tries to kill him
Aria was moving just as smooth as this
white Walker was and we haven't seen the
best of arias skills yet Aria has
already had some of the best training
you can ask for so far she built a nice
foundation while she practiced with
Syrio Forel back in season one and now
she hadn't actually trained with the
helm but he did teach her some very
valuable lessons and of course she got
her ninja-like skills from her time
spent at the house of black and white
while training with Jack and Hagar and
the wife and now she's already begun to
train with Brienne although it was quick
I don't think this is going to be the
last time that these two train together
and this is where Aria can build up her
strength because she's already got her
quickness down with all this knowledge
and skills combined she's going to be
very formidable when the dead come
marching on Westeros and having that
Valyrian steel dagger puts her at the
top of the list for characters who are
going to kill some white walkers
alongside of Jon Snow
all this Valyrian steel was making its
way up north for a reason when the long
night sets over Westeros and the Dead
get south of the wall I believe every
single Valyrian steel sword is going to
be in the north at that point because
this will be the first line of defense
before the white walkers and white
can get any further south John's going
to be back in Winterfell with Longclaw
very soon in Brienne is already there
with Oathkeeper now in Oriya now has de
Valera and still dagger and I think
similarly is going to lead the Citadel
with this father sword hearts babe and I
think Jaime Lannister is going to end up
in the north - with what Oz well there's
only 10 episodes left now so we're
getting very close to actually seeing
the war that I know I've been waiting
for since the very first episode and I'm
getting very anxious to see it and to
see what Arya can do also this Valyrian
steel dagger that she now has also
popped up in the book that Sam o Tarly
was reading back in Episode one of this
season and that definitely has some
significance - not only is the steel
Valyrian but the handle has also made
out a dragon bone and Dragons obviously
are very magical and this dagger has
multiple magical properties inside of it
there is also a red ruby inside the
dagger and when I look at this red ruby
and the dagger it makes me think of
Rhaegar Targaryen because Rhaegar
Targaryen also had red rubies in his
armor - now that this will be in close
proximity of Jon this could end up
having a connection to Jon - especially
now that it's back in the north for a
reason and they showed us this picture
and the book Sam was reading for a
reason - but that might sound - tinfoil
II you could say it's really only
relevant to the plot to be used to kill
Littlefinger but I have a feeling it's
going to be more important even after
that
considering who Arya Stark has become
what else could you see her doing for
the rest of the series she's not just
going to use this dagger one time then
put it on the shelf it's probably going
to stay on her hip at all times unless
it's in her hand while she's killing
someone and hopefully that someone has
some White Walkers when the time comes
so comment down below and let me know
what you thought about the quick
sparring scene with Arya and Brienne
assuming you have seen the episode or at
least this clip let me know if you'd
like to seen or not how awesome did Arya
look against Brienne I'm very curious to
see where her story leads now that she's
back in the North right before the wall
comes down and she has Valyrian steel
now this dagger is a perfect weapon for
an assassin and that's exactly what Arya
has became I will be releasing my full
review and breakdown of this episode
after it airs on Sunday night so thanks
for coming by and watching this video
I'll be heading down into the comments
section to try and catch up on all the
new comments that I've received over the
past 48 hours so hopefully I'll see all
of you down there too then one last
thing before I go I have to thank all of
my patreon supporters thank you all so
much for your continued support of this
channel I really appreciate that and I
hope everyone has a good day
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]